I'm uh Fox harell I'm associate
professor here of digital media uh I run
a lab called the imagination computation
and expression laboratory focused on
combining computer science cognitive
science and digital media arts for
interactive narrative gaming and social
media related systems and one of the
things that we're excited to do this
year is to start off a series which is
called the cognitive dimensions of media
to bring in a series of people who are
thinking about uh media from a cognitive
perspective but not just from uh a kind
of uh order fashion cognition is
everything just in the head perspective
but really looking at cognition as
embodied uh as distributed amongst
society and amongst artifacts and
situated in particular social context
and today we're honored as I'll
introduce in a moment to have uh
Professor George Lov out here from UC
Berkeley the discussion will be uh
moderated by Professor Heather
Hendershot uh she's a professor of film
and media studies here uh here in the
front row
uh she's in the communication study
communication compared to media studies
Department she's written on rightwing uh
broadcasting on children's programming
she's the editor of Cinema Journal Al
the author of uh multiple notable books
this uh talk series is also co-sponsored
by the communications forum and uh today
we're very pleased to introduce the
distinguished speaker who is uh George
Lov as you know who needs no
introduction but uh we'll get one anyway
so so he graduated from here in uh
1962 so uh double major course uh 21 and
Mathematics that's uh uh writing
mathematics studied literature uh
luminary figures uh or here Roman
yakobson help bridging Poetics along
with Linguistics one of the first people
in the in uh students in the Linguistics
Department here and uh especially
notably was a pioneer of incorporating
logic based approaches into Linguistics
so using mathematics to express
Linguistics
Concepts on the other hand uh he's also
notable for uh running up against not
only the Innovations of that approach
but also some of the challenges and
limitations so pioneered also the kind
of embodied cognition approach that
involves movement emotions affective
disposition perception and much more
within cognitive science uh and what's
even more exciting to me is that it's a
particular kind of cognition that looks
at the central role of poetic thinking
that's figurative uh thinking metaphor
and the way that these kinds of
figurative and poetic and literary uh
thought are the basis for everyday
cognition uh so much of most of you
probably already know a lot a lot of
this uh work he segued into also work on
moral politics using cognitive Science
Foundation his most recent book is the
little blue book uh you his classic
books I suspect you also already know
and so I want you to join me in
welcoming very warmly Professor George
[Applause]
LOF is that up there
yet um I don't think that's yes it's
there great all right thank you all for
coming it's great to be back at MIT um
I've been here a few times uh since I
graduated 50 years ago and it's changed
a bit uh this spot used to be the Neco
Factory from Neco Wafers uh and smelled
all over campus but uh this is a lot
better
um I want to begin uh by talking about
metaphorical thought and I want to I'm
going to break it down in three parts
first that then the neural theory of
thought and life language and then what
the brain tells us about politics and uh
let me tell you a bit about how I got
into the study of metaphorical thought
uh in
1978 in February uh I was teaching a
freshman not a freshman undergraduate
seminar at Berkeley with six students
sitting around a table about this size
and um uh I had um given out various
papers to read uh and one of them was a
paper on metaphor by a noted philosopher
uh which I didn't think was a very good
paper but we were going to read it and
um the uh it was raining as it's always
raining in Berkeley in February uh and
um on that day one of the young women in
the class came in a little bit late
drenched and in
tears and she sat down across the table
she was about you know 4 feet away and
uh she was crying and no everybody tried
not to notice that she was crying uh so
we went around the table what is you
know Professor so and so says this in
this article what do you think about
that we get to her and she says I'm
sorry I've got a metaphor problem with
my
boyfriend maybe you guys can help well
this is Berkeley in
1978 we all said
sure and we all knew what to
do so we started an instant support
group and we said well you know what did
he say and she said well he said that
our relationship had hit a dead end
Street and I don't know what he means by
this so we said well look we started
immediately doing linguistic fieldwork
uh you know what what could he mean uh
you know if you can't keep going the way
you've been going you may have to turn
back and then we started noticing that
there was certain
Expressions uh about uh love using a
travel
vocabulary so we you know this is a
Linguistics class I say hey that's
interesting let's make a list linguists
do this how many Expressions can we find
of uh about love from travel well uh you
know there's lots of them um it's been a
long bumpy road the marriage is on the
Rocks we're spinning our Wheels in this
relationship uh the the the relationship
is off the track we're going in
different directions we may have to bail
out
and so on and um in fact the young woman
was a disc jockey on the local radio
show at camp on campus and she said oh
yeah there's been a um uh a new rock
song came out this week with the lyrics
uh where um driving in the fast lane on
the freeway of love and everybody
understood this well uh you know now I'm
a Linguistics professor and so um I
realized that um there was a problem
immediately uh Aristotle uh 2500 years
before by all means come on down we have
chairs don't don't don't be shy you know
lots and lots of seats don't don't worry
about it come on in lots of seats down
here in the middle you know in front
come
on SO 25 200 years ago Aristotle said
that metaphor was a matter of language
and uh of similarities and it was all a
matter of uh special language that
occurred in in poetry or in politics and
things like that but wasn't ordinary the
ordinary use of language and I realized
first of all that uh what was going on
was did not quite fit what Aristotle
said because you had lots of different
linguistic Expressions but they all had
the same conceptual metaphor they all
understood in terms of Love is a journey
of a certain kind and so I said well
this is interesting we have a nice list
is there any generalization about this
list so we sat down we said uh okay um
notice in each case the lovers are
Travelers in each case the relationship
is some kind of vehicle a car a train a
plane a boat whatever uh and in each
case uh the difficulties are impediments
to travel and each case the lovers are
trying to get to some common destination
uh which meant their Comm life goals and
there that the problem and and every
expression was a problem with getting
there okay so we write this down and you
know it looks kind of like a mapping in
math you write it down you have a little
arrow you go to that there were little
four little arrows there was a little
nice little mapping and so um I said hey
Isn't that cool and the young woman said
I don't care about your
mapping my boyfriend is breaking up with
me he's thinking in terms of this
metaphor I said well that's interesting
how do you think in terms of a metaphor
how does this work let's take an example
we're spinning our Wheels in this
relationship well what do we know um is
there a metal image here uh where are
the
wheels where are the wheels
guys they're are they on something or
they just
Wheels in a car or you know little truck
or whatever yeah they're in a car and
they're spinning is the car
moving no do you want it to be
moving are you putting any energy into
it how do you
feel how did you all know the right
answer right everybody knows the right
answer but now if you take that mapping
and you say what happens it says you're
in a relationship it's not going
anywhere you're not making progress
towards your common life goals you're
putting a lot of energy into it and
you're frustrated that's what it means
to you know be spinning your wheels in a
relationship that is there's an
inference from this there's metaphorical
reasoning going on that mapping is
taking what you know about the what we
call The Source domain of travel and
mapping it on to
love Aristotle didn't say that not only
that it's trickier because I had
previously spent uh from 1963 until then
about 15 years trying to get logic to
work for natural language and trying to
get the the theory that meaning was
based on truth conditions to work right
now if meaning is based on truth
conditions on how words fit the world or
symbols fit the world where that where
is this
metaphor can't be in the
world can't be in the relationship
between that and the world it's got to
be in your
head wait a minute that's not what
philosophers say that's not what
anglo-american philosophy teaches it's
not even what postmodernist uh European
philosophy
teaches something is wrong here or maybe
right something interesting has just
happened there is metaphorical
thought and the metaphorical thought is
in form in the form of a mapping from
one domain of experience to another and
it has lots of
different very different expressions
with different meanings but they're all
part of that
generalization that's
cool okay um the woman did not make up
with her boyfriend but she graduated got
her PhD got a nice job met a nice guy
who also they both got tenure and
they're
fine and she she's even a department
chairman right now but I won't tell you
where
now
um the main part of this is that for
after that I spent about a year
collecting examples of this and a year
later Mark Johnson happened to show up
in Berkeley and we happened to start
working uh on a book H and three months
later there was a book called metaphors
we live by that came out uh and uh we
had to finish it in 3 mon months because
Mark had to go on vacation with his wife
he promised his wife he would leave so
we finished it in three months now the
big thing about that was we noticed that
there were lots and lots of other
metaphors metaphorical thought and in
particular we noticed that some of them
had to do with the
body so for example uh something like um
uh Happy is up and sad is down I'm
feeling up to today I'm depressed I'm
down I'm in the dumps Etc right that has
to do with the way your body
works uh and we found lots of others
that had to do with experience like more
is up and less is down why every time
you pour water in the glass the ever
level go up you P more pile more stuff
on the table the level goes up every day
all around the world this happens so we
started looking at the ones that were
like that and then we noticed something
about good old love as a journey
that it got decomposed could be
decomposed into other conceptual
metaphors that had to do with
embodiment in
particular why is it that you have
um uh Journeys being understood as
reaching goals achieving a goal is you
know uh is reaching a destination and
the difficulty is something that's St
stops you from reaching that goal well
think about it for a minute uh every day
you know you want a coffee you got to go
to where they sell the coffees uh you
want a cold beer you got to go to the
fridge constantly every baby wants his
blanket he's got to crawl over and get
it you know want to be snuggly you got
to get into bed I mean this is crucial
every day of your life there's a
correlation in your experience between
achieving a purpose and reaching a
destination just as as a correlation and
experience between um pouring water into
the glass getting more water and seeing
the level go up and we started noticing
lots of those for example you also have
things like why is it that a
relationship uh is a
vehicle one relationships are containers
you're in a relationship you enter a
relationship you can leave a
relationship you can be deep into a
relationship Etc okay it's a container
why is it a container
when you're kid you live with your
relatives your relations in one
contained Place yeah very simple
correlation and experience intimacy is
closeness you're close in this car why
is intimacy and closeness the people
you're most intimate with are the people
you've been close to from the time
you're a kid um why is it that it's a
what about vehicles vehicles are used to
take you places purposes or destinations
right so there's a reason why their
relationship is a vehicle in there but
it has to do with embodied
experience but then there's a further
thing that we noticed when we started
looking around at other cultures the
embodied experience cases seem to be
widespread around the world if not
Universal because many of the
experiences are Universal but things
like love is a journey is not Universal
ival there are lots of cultures that
don't have that so we sort of wondered
why should that be well we noticed also
that you have a metaphor that life is a
journey but a very different kind but
it's interesting uh and there's a reason
for it there's a general metaphor that
goes like this that action is motion so
uh you know a careful action is careful
motion like walking on eggshells
uh walking a fine line things like that
and and we can go through that there's a
long list of these action is motion
cases and achieving a purpose is
reaching a destination so a purposeful
action is motion toward a destination
and then what's a life it's a sequence
of actions toward some Des various
destinations but in this culture there's
something more we require a purposeful
life you're supposed to be achieving
life goals not just immediate goals like
what am I going to do for dinner or
something like that but life
goals now we even have documents for
this they're called curriculum
V the Run of Life the course of life
right and uh you're supposed to tell
where you are at various courses places
in life and you all know about these
documents you write them and you've seen
them and you read them all the time now
uh so this is important and then well
what how does that relate to love as a
journey think about two people in a
longterm love relationship they're
supposed to both of them are supposed to
have purposes in life but they're
supposed to be compatible purposes in
life any of you ever had the problem of
having such compatible purposes in life
yeah I have and many of you have like
you right I mean it's not so easy to be
in a long-term love relationship where
there are compatible purposes in life
and this metaphor is about those
difficulties right now when you put all
this together you find out that you have
a structure that is very
interesting and it's a hierarchical
structure where let's put at the top
just for the sake of uh you know uh the
embodied metaphors that are basic we
call them primary metaphors the ones
that are widespread around the world and
here you go action is motion purposes or
destinations and they entail the
difficulties are impediments to reaching
a destination and there is a composite
metaphor purposeful action is motion to
a destination and that fits certain
frames so life is a sequence of actions
performed over a lifetime and there's a
structure a sequence of regions uh of
life like childhood adulthood and so
on now you also have entailed metaphors
like a life is a sequence of motions and
so
on a purposeful purposeful life is a
sequence of motions toward
destinations sorry difficulties in a
purposeful life are impediments to
reaching those and a journey is a long
sequence of motions to one or more
destinations so you get life is a
journey and there's a cultural norm
people are expected to have purposes in
life love is a Journey has this cultural
norm lovers in a long-term relationship
are expected to have compatible purposes
in life that entails a metaphor
compatible purposes are common
destinations uh this is all metaphorical
logic uh a relationship is a container a
bounded region in space intimacy is
closeness and you get a vehicle as a
means of reaching destinations in a
two-person vehicle The Travelers are
close the vehicle is solid can last a
long time a two-person vehicle is a
means for reaching common
destinations and then you get a
long-term love relationship is a
two-person vehicle lovers or Travelers
Etc all of those uh a long-term love
relationship is a means for reaching
common life goals the difficulties are
impediments and relationship
difficulties are impediments to reaching
compatible
destinations to understand something
like the marriages on the Rocks you have
to know all of
that and you have an image a cultural
image the boat on the rocks and in that
the boat is the vehicle the boat on the
Rocks can't move can be damaged can be
less solid The Travelers can be hurt a
possibility of getting off the Rocks is
is you know there possible but you could
do it and then there are mappings the
boat is the relationship the motion is
progress third common life goals and
there are inferences the love lovers
could be psychologically harmed the life
will likelihood the relationship will
last is lowered and so on that is you
take your knowledge about the boat on
the rocks for the marriages on the Rocks
you apply the general mapping and you
have to have all of that together to
know what that means all of it at once
and there are lots of other cases that
train off the track the marriag is off
the relationships off the track you know
track off they can't move the deadend
street case the spinning its Wheels case
car being stuck we're stuck in this
relationship we got to bail out it's
been a long Buffy Road we're not going
anywhere this is a a wreck and so on
notice each of them is a different
specific metaphor with different
entailments but the entailments come
from knowledge about the
image apply that mapping and you get the
meaning of the specific metaphor so what
you have are primary
metaphors that are based on experience
and embodied experience you have
composite metaphors and lots of
inferences that go on that whole thing
you have cultural norms you have to be
concerned with and then each of these
fits the composite metaphor and they
each give different entailments
depending on what the metaphor
maps that is how metaphor works and it's
conceptual and then the language fits
the
image and then you ask well how many
images do like that do you have and the
answer is tens of
thousands that's what it means means to
to know a
culture okay now what is this list of of
relationships uh within the neural
theory of language and thought it's
called a Cascade Cascades in the brain
are U circuits that control the
activation of things going on all over
the brain at often at once and that's
what you need
here okay so that's a nice example
of what a me metaphor is you got a
simple case and you can see what you're
going to need in a brainbase theory of
this is Cascades of at least this
complexity okay normal is that
cool how many of Cascades are there
going to be a
lot all right how does the brain do
this how many neurons you have 100
billion at Birth how many many
connections to other neurons for each of
them between a th and 10,000 and gives
you about a quadrillion connections at
Birth by the time you're five about half
of them have died the ones that are
least used which is why you need early
childhood education okay but that only
leads you with half a quadrillion
connections right
now every thought you have we'll go to
this but first of all there's a a
general Point here you know that is we
have primary metaphors specific
knowledge all of these things we just
said okay and notice if you ignore the
general metaphor and just do the
analysis on the specific cases there
would be dozens of different Journey
metaphors and you wouldn't see any
generalization across them and you
wouldn't be able to to know what a new a
new rock song meant okay now so the
point here is important metaphor is a
natural mode of thought it arises
spontaneously it shapes how we think how
we reason how we understand the world
mathematics is also cognitively a system
of precise embodied metaphors and mafel
Nunes and I have a 600 page book full in
full detail easy to read but lots of fun
but it goes through I was an
undergraduate math major here it goes
through what I learned in my
undergraduate math curriculum in detail
of what the metaphors are precisely in
formal terms and what it CHS is we what
advanced math is is a a a Cascade of
metaphors that start with things like
arithmetic and geometry and so on and
then build metaphorically on those and
those are metaphorically based on
experiences like putting things in
containers and taking them out which is
why uh addition is adding something and
subtraction is taking taken away uh it
has to do with with taking steps as you
move uh you know which is why you have
uh the number line and so on and what we
do is we work out the entailments of
those metaphors in full detail in this
book and it's
cheap you can pick it up you know go and
get one and and you'll and not only that
it shows that formulas mean
things mathematical formulas mean things
and the way we set up the book was this
my favorite formula when I was in high
school was e to Pi I + 1al equal zero
right great Oiler
metaphor uh we show what it means and
why it's true and showing that it it
requires putting together metaphors from
five branches of mathematics it's an
80-page demonstration at the end of the
book enjoy it if you're into this now
also scientific theories use conceptual
metaphor in their content think of
SpaceTime you know where time is
understood in terms of space which is a
standard metaphor we have for
understanding uh space in terms of time
not just here but around the world so uh
basically metaphor is Central in both
Technical and everyday reasoning and
it's
everywhere now the problem with this is
it contradicts what I learned here as
the theory of rationality and reason
here's what I learned thought is
conscious as dayart said this is
straight out of
1650 um say thought is conscious thought
is abstract not physical emotion gets in
the way of reason reason uses
mathematical logic reason can directly
fit the world reason is what makes us
human therefore all humans have the same
reason the job of reason is to serve our
interests and words are defined by
conditions of Truth in the world what
cognitive science and Neuroscience have
shown is that every part of that is
false every single part all right now um
just to give you a sense of that before
we go through the new Theory let me go
through some of this first about 98% of
thought is
unconscious it could not be conscious
because Consciousness is linear and
thought is massively
parallel it could not be conscious and
it isn't and it's well below the
Consciousness thought is not abstract
it's all physical if you don't have the
neural circuitry for for the right
neural circuitry for understanding
something you won't understand it you
can only understand what the circuitry
of your brain allows you to understand
and that is profound when it comes to
Politics as really we'll
see you should you're laughing huh you
should be
crying uh it's unfortunately true
emotion does not get in the way of
reason motion is required for reason
there's a marvelous book on this by Tony
damasio called decart's error Tony is
one of our great
neuroscientists and uh for many years he
studied he has studied people with brain
Legions particularly those who've had
car accidents or strokes and so on and
there's one there are certain people who
lose the ability to feel emotion because
of Strokes or or
lesions and when that happens they like
and not like don't mean anything and
they can't tell if anybody else would
like or not like what they do so they
can't set
goals they can't set goals they can't
rationally pursue any goals because they
can't set any goals and they wind up
acting kind of randomly screwing up
their lives in most
cases this is a deep point you must be
rational I mean to must be emotional to
be rational you can't be rational
without
emotions not there not possible Right
Next uh reason does not just use
mathematical logic it uses metaphor it
uses uh what are called frames that
we'll get to it uses what are called
image schemers we'll get to those but it
uses certainly it uses lots and lots and
lots of
metaphors uh reason presum is what makes
us human therefore we all have the same
reason not true just think about the
Republican and Democratic national
conventions not the same
reason right and we'll talk about that
in a while we don't all have the same
reason we have different neural
circuitry for doing
reasoning next the job of reason is
supposed to be to serve our
interests well it is to a large extent
that's not false but there's another
thing even more important um in the
early to mid 1990s there was a great
discovery made in Parma Italy uh in the
Neuroscience group there the discovery
of mirror neuron
circuitry now uh and I worked with one
of the discoverers vorio Galazy at some
uh detail working on the primary data
that they had and um basically the think
of it it this way they started out with
doing research on Max and they have put
probes in the max brain where they can
go neuron by neuron and see in the
premotor cortex which choreographs
what's going on in the motor cortex they
they put probes in to see what would
happen when they trained the monkey to
uh peel bananas uh you know um Crush
peanuts uh pull push on bars uh pull on
ropes and so on they they taught them to
do these things and as they did them you
know different neurons with fire and
they kept track by computer of exactly
what neurons with fire and to make sure
the computer was operating they made it
go click click click click click so they
could hear that it was working okay so
uh Victorio is running this one day
everything's going fine he goes out to
lunch comes back he's still a little
hungry there's a pile of bananas he goes
to peel a banana and he hears click
click click click
click but the the machine's tied up to
the monkey not
him why they check the data and it turns
out that the banana peeling part of the
brain of the monkey was
engaged and then they tested and they
found out that the same uh part of the
brain that was used for acting was used
when you perceived the same action done
by someone else well that's the
mythology the reality is more
complicated and interesting it's only
30% of those neurons the other neurons
are doing more interesting stuff like uh
giving a semantic hierarchy going
through the semantic sequences of act
parts of the action uh you know saying
what's Central when it's finished when
it's beginning doing all kinds of other
things as well as uh you know for both
uh seeing and doing but there's
circuitry that links seeing and doing
and then they trace the circuitry to the
parietal cortex Premo to parietal not
that far and we learned we have are born
with that circuitry and then it gets
tuned as we grow up to to fit what we
see and what we do in addition that
circuitry in Premo cortex is connected
to the emotional
regions what that means is that through
we know from Paul ekman's work that
there's a physiology of emotions you go
around the world and you know people are
happy smile and smiles look the same way
and use the same muscles and if you're
sad other other muscles are involved and
if you're angry you bury your teeth and
so on there's a whole physiology of
emotions that has been studied in great
detail and that means that the
physiology which is controlled by the
Premo cortex is connected to the
emotions which allows you to tell when
someone else is happy or someone else is
in pain or someone else is sad or angry
it is the basis of empathy it also Al
allows you to tell when someone else
picks up a bottle like this and goes
like this that I'm about to take a
drink and I was and you could tell and
then they found out that there are what
are called canonical
neurons so um those are oh few
millimeters away Along a certain Ridge
and they fire when either you perform an
action or you see something you can
perform it on like this
bottle see wouldn't you like a drink
now we are envir evolutionarily
constructed to have brains that connect
with other people emotionally and with
what they're doing and by the way the
murans fire more in Cooperative action
than in just you know
noticing in addition we are set up to
connect with the world what is a
canonical neuron it fires when you
perform the normal canonical action of
this so I hold this up and you have
taking a drink not sticking it in my
ear right that's not the canonical
action this is it and that's what's
important here we are we are
environmentally linked to objects in the
world via what we normally canonically
do with those objects in the
world that's wild and that says the job
of reason is everything to do with
connecting to things in the world via
our bodies and connecting to other
people via our bodies not just carrying
out our goals which is also
important and then what does this say
about the idea that reason can directly
fit the
world it can only fit it via our
bodies by our the way our brain and body
connects us to the world if you know you
can't just it doesn't just fit
automatically you got to be able to
connect to your body connect to your
brain and then you might be able to get
the fit but the only fit is what your
brain allows you to
understand okay
words fit these neural structures they
fit frames they fit metaphors and so on
words don't directly connect to things
in the
world okay so that is pretty
cool so here you have a new theory of
real reason it's based on what putting
together Neuroscience
neurocomputation cognitive Linguistics
and embodied cognition experiments and
this is the basic idea we think with our
brains all thought is physical carried
out by neural circuitry most thought
almost usually 98% is the estimate is
unconscious you can only understand what
your neural circuitry allows you to
understand emotion is needed for reason
rationality requires emotion the basic
mechanisms thought thought are embodied
conceptual Primitives now these are
interesting um they are what are called
schema circuits and they have embodied
roles and so on let me explain what they
are uh there are spatial circuits for
things like um uh containment something
is in or out of something so you have
that you have uh a container schema has
an interior exterior and a boundary uh a
motion schema has a source a path and a
goal and so on those are called semantic
roles and we have lots of them dozens if
not hundreds of those uh we have action
schemas that carry those out seren and
oryan and uh figured out how they work
uh back in
1995 uh and um what he showed was that
you can model them computationally um uh
you know using uh standard kinds of
computation fixed up a lot to make it
look
neural uh and um they have structure and
what he did was show what it would take
to model the uh the uh the kinds of
actions you perform with your body he
did this for lots and lots of bodily
actions and found that the same
structure was used for all of them and
when he showed up with that structure I
noticed that that structure shows up in
every language of the world it's called
aspect in linguistics and what it means
is it's the structure of actions and
events as they are structured in every
language so we have things like um I'm
about to take a
drink be just before the beginning I
started to take a drink I picked this up
I'm taking a drink I'm in the
middle I'm still taking a
drink I'm checking to see if I'm still
thirsty no I'm fine then I can put it
down i f finish and after I'm done
there's a consequence I have taken a
drink that's what have with I means and
so on and every language of the world
can express stuff like that now so proc
those are called process schemas
sometimes called ex schemas or executing
schemas and then there's neural binding
if you're going to put together various
metaphors to form complex metaphors they
have to be bound nothing moves in the
brain so you have to have circuitry that
binds them together called neural
binding and we're working out theories
of neural binding right now uh there are
frames what are called frame circuits
for uh framing uh actions like uh riding
on a boat for example or driving a car
uh there are what are called metan nmic
mappings where you say things like we
need a strong arm at third base where
the arm stands for the person um and
lots of others uh the White House isn't
talking uh or is talking as in the the
um
cartoons uh there are metaphorical
mappings that you've seen these are
neural uh mappings the primary ones are
for body schemas Etc and there are
composite ones that are bindings and so
on now how does this
happen and what's interesting is that
nin in his dissertation after he worked
out how actions worked for concrete AC
actions I then asked them okay if you
can do that can you get a logic of
abstract
actions and Abstract events well he said
to do that you need metaphor to map from
the more embodied ones to the quote
abstract ones they turn out not to be
abstract we'll get there in a minute to
the other ones that are not physically
out there in the
world and so he picked the domain of
international economics where an economy
goes forward up or down or into
depressions and recessions and gets
pulled out or not and so on and then he
went online to the New York Times
business section The Wall Street Journal
and The Economist with uh a list of
simple actions that uh he had analyzed
in terms of what your body did uh so
things like um uh India is stumbling
toward economic
liberalization or um France fell into a
recession pulled out by Germany Etc and
he asked uh could you then create a
neural a computational neural theory of
metaphor that would go along with the
what the body does to give you all the
right inferences and he did that was his
dissertation
1997 and uh the idea is basically
this that how do you learn let's say uh
uh affection is warmth
okay we all have that you know he's a
warm person he's cool to me Etc okay uh
how do you you know how do you learn
that well you're held affectionately by
your parents and you feel their bodily
warmth what's happening in your
brain two different parts of the brain
are activated one for temperature one
for affection they're in different parts
of the
brain okay same thing for MO is up
there's a part of the brain that
registers verticality and a part that
registers
quantity so what happens when they are
activated over and over together well
the more you activate a neural circuit
the stronger it gets and since H neurons
connected to lots of others and the
circuit is not just on one neuron at a
time it's a neuronal group of usually
several hundred neurons you have
connections along existing Pathways and
those you get spreading activation along
that and then you get more spreading
activation and it gets stronger each
time via heavan learning because uh
neurons that fire together wire together
and so you get hean learning and you get
uh the shortest connection between these
is eventually found and you form a
circuit but at this point you get Spike
time dependent plasticity coming into
effect which adjusts the structure of
the circuits what that does is
strengthen connection
that are in the direction of more
spiking and weaken ones that are in the
direction of less first
spiking now what determines more spiking
and less spiking in the metaphor cases
let's take affection as warmth your
brain is
always uh Computing temperature but not
always Computing affection your brain is
always Computing verticality even when
you sleep in order to turn over over but
not always Computing quantity so what's
going on is that when you have more
going on more input you're going to get
more first spiking and you're going to
get
asymmetric uh connections and metaphors
are
asymmetric now we've then checked out
several hundred of these primary
metaphors and they all
work we can predict the directionality
of the metaphors on the basis of the
neural circuitry is that
cool I like
it uh this is all seren work um I didn't
do it he did it
now so
um what we have is a thing called
Cascade Theory a Cascade is a neural
pathway along which you have circuits
that determine the activation flow in
the brain and that's what first did when
he was looking at the activation flow
for ACT simple actions for sequence of
actions it determined activation flow in
the brain but activation flow in the
premotor cortex but this the same
mathematics and the same circuitry the
same neural computation will work for
all flows of activation in the brain and
we're now working out all the circuitry
for frames metaphors etc for how that
works and that's called Cascade Theory
and we know that there are Cascades for
lots of other things and I if you want I
can go through some others later that we
know exist but that's what we're going
to need uh and um flow along a Cascade
can originate either internally or
externally that is can be perceived
something you hear in language or you
can make it up not only that you can
make up things internally that can't
exist like flying
pigs right now imagine a flying pig
okay how does it
fly what allows it to
fly wings where are the
wings are the wings on its
feet on the back which way is the snout
oriented direction of motion in the
direction of motion you all know the
answer to that how did you know
it right you knew it because you could
do neural binding of pigs and birds this
this is pigasus by the
way you could do neural binding of
pigasus and you know the optimal binding
which is called best fit which we'll
talk about in a while and that allows
you to create something internally that
can't exist but flying pigs there
another there's another kind of flying
pig U called super swine uh he has a
cape and goes like this right and so on
okay and you now understand sup swine
instantly you know it you know so you
can do this and you do it internally or
externally now what does all this have
to do with politics so I'm going to zip
ahead uh and go on to politics from all
of this I won't go through all of the
the details of this best fit is going to
be in there Etc best fit is interesting
because it has it comes from uh the fact
that we're a physical system and we use
conservation of energy and the neurons
the neural circuits uh that are
activated are the ones that will use the
least overall energy that is the ones
with the strongest
connections and you can model that
computationally by Bas
Nets uh which is what's been done uh in
our lab
now what is this have to do with
politics
first Charles Filmore back in 19
1975 observed that language is defined
relative to what are called frames they
are neural structures in the brain that
have various roles uh classic example of
Roger Shanks the restaurant frame you
have a waiter you have a chef you have a
customer you have a menu you have a dish
those are the roles and you know the
order in which things occur that's a
scenario that fits that defines a frame
and then there are various inferences
from that
okay so those are real and uh metaphors
is map from frame to frame what's
interesting is that negating a frame
activates the frame
neurally just that's why I wrote a book
called don't think of an
elephant makes you think of an elephant
Nixon said I am not a
crook
okay U who's the uh Christine what's her
name uh in running uh in South was it in
the Carolinas said I am not a witch
remember that one anyway is it Delaware
she said I am not a witch because
through the
election for good reason now uh the more
frame is activated the stronger the
frame circuitry gets they come in
hierarchies Now The crucial thing is all
politics is
moral now in case that isn't obvious
it's very simple think of it this way
every political leader gets up and says
here's what you should do we should pass
this legislation that legislation Etc
because it's right nobody gets up and
says do it because it's wrong it's evil
do it or it doesn't matter do it the
assumption is it's right they just have
different ideas about what right is
different
moralities what that means is that there
is a frame hierarchy which we know
exists and that the highest part of that
hierarchy is in politics is moral and
that everything in the frame hierarchy
all those policies have to fit the moral
system and these moral I described these
moral systems in a book called moral
politics in
1996 now um and we'll talk about it in a
while but they have very different moral
systems now the moral systems are
General the policies that fit them are
specific so you have lots of Cascades
going on now interest L very important
to know is B conceptualism there are a
lot of people who are partly
conservative and partly Progressive
neurally this means that they have both
neural circuitries in their in the same
brain now they contradict each other how
is that possible the answer is very
simple Mutual inhibition there are
circuits in the brain all over the brain
where one circuit inhibits the other the
activation of One turns the other off
right right now this isn't just in
politics with moral systems think about
the following there are cases where you
where many many people have two opposed
moral systems and they don't even notice
when they switch just think Saturday
night and Sunday
morning very common this is not an this
is not a weird uh phenomenon so many
people are boncal and usually in
politics they are have different moral
systems applying to different things so
they're not applying to the same thing
they're you know conservative about some
things and others and they're called
moderates swing voters Etc but what is a
moderate it's somebody who is largely
conservative but uh Progressive about
something or other or largely
Progressive but conservative about
something or other and then there are
swing voters okay
now how do you influence a moderate or
an independent or swing vter or Bic
conceptual you use your language to
activate your moral system to strengthen
it and weaken the other the last thing
you do is use their
language conservatives are taught this
in training institutes like the
Leadership Institute in Virginia that
trains tens of thousands of
conservatives every year and they are
spread in along around the country and
in other
countries uh they're in Europe they're
in Canada they're in Australia they're
in Korea Etc and they're taught how to
think and talk conservative and what to
do and what not to do but our guys often
make the mistake of thinking you have to
go the other way why because they
believe in Enlightenment
reason Enlightenment reason says if you
want to communicate with someone and
convince them you should talk their
language it's fine language is neutral
just fits the world no it
doesn't language is not neutral it fits
frames that fit different moral systems
in
politics very crucial point and a lot of
Point many Democrats Miss why because
they went to
college now I'm not I'm I'm quite
serious um suppose you are conservative
and you take a business course in
college in your curriculum there will be
marketing and the marketing professors
study psychology how people people
really think right so conservatives have
no problem marketing their ideas using
all of this
stuff but liberals who want to go into
politics study political science law
public policy and economics and they
learn the rational actor model and uh
Enlightenment reason they learn a false
theory of
reason and that false theory of reason
leads them not to understand how brains
work it leads them not to understand
that they shouldn't that they should use
their language about their moral systems
not the other guy's language it leads
them it means that they don't understand
they have to set up a system of
communication where they repeat
repetition is what changes brains even
if it were true that everybody thought
according to tr traditional reason the
fact that thought is physical means if
you convince someone and somebody you're
changing their brain changing brains is
not
manipulation it is smart in politics
that's how it works and the
conservatives have been doing this
consistently since the 1960s in you know
I I could go through all the
institutions and so on that they've set
up for it but it's that mind change is
Brain Change
arguing against opponents using their
language and negating the frame just
helps
them okay
example uh how many of you saw Bill
Clinton's
speech hey uh I liked it I thought it
was a great speech and what he did was
he corrected the misconceptions right so
the next day I walk into class and I say
okay you you see Clinton speech Yes what
was great about it he corrected all the
false claims okay
uh you know that he gave us the truth uh
the real facts all right how many of you
remember the facts tell me how many of
you remember at least one
fact one person in this class of 40 at
Berkeley very smart undergraduates
remembered three facts and that was it
for the whole class now how many people
remembered the Republican claims that
Clinton was arguing against
everybody think about that for a
moment and they this was brought up on
Fox News and one of the Romney advisers
said this Clinton speech doesn't matter
people won't remember what he
said it's not entirely true because what
he got across was you can't trust
them even though people might not
remember the exact
facts so it did have a major effect but
not the effect that a lot of liberals
thought it had I mean you'd have to
carry the the thing around with you to
remember all of them unless you're a
political junkie like me now um this is
important because if you turn on MSNBC
you will see uh lots of people uh using
uh the other guys language and arguing
against them by negating their frames
and therefore strength in
them right notice it next time you turn
on liberal pundits
notice now the big thing about this
about morality is morality is all
metaphorical and that's not obvious but
it's
true morality is about well-being your
well-being and the well-being of others
and that is registered chemically in the
brain we have Pathways for um positive
and negative
emotions okay that is things that that
are that have to do with our well-being
and our ill beinging the positive
emotion Pathways go past things like
happiness awe satisfaction and so on the
negative ones go past things like uh
anger sadness fear uh disgust and so on
okay so the way to think about this is
think about the metaphors your for
Morality you're going to learn on the
basis of the activation of satisfaction
and
dissatisfaction uh Pathways paired with
other experiences because that's how you
learn primary metaphors when they're
paired you learn the
circuitry and they ask okay when you're
a child uh which is better eating pure
food or rotten
food Pure Food morality is Purity
immorality is rottenness something is
even rotten in the state of Denmark okay
that was a rotten thing to do
purification rituals occur around the
world every one-year-old knows that it's
you're better off if you can stand ight
than if you have to crawl on the ground
so morality is being upstanding
immorality is being a low down snake
morality is light immorality is Darkness
because you're better off if you're
functioning in the light than in the
dark around the world you get uh things
like this in in Japanese you have the
Hara Center of emotions having a black
Hara is being immoral in Mung having a
black liver is being immoral in Swahili
having a black stomach is being immoral
nothing to do with skin color it has to
do with light and dark uh morality is
beauty immorality is ugliness that was a
beautiful thing to do you're better off
if you're good-looking than if you're
not even as a baby all right things are
getting ugly around here as uh Perry
said uh you know if uh so and so banki
comes to Texas it's going to get ugly
now uh well-being is wealth you you're
better off if you have the things you
need than if you don't and then you have
moral accounting if I do you a favor
that increases your well-being you say
I'm in your debt how can I repay you you
know I owe you one right moral action is
accumulating moral credit and moral
action is balancing the moral books in
in these cases morality is you're better
off if you listen to your parents than
if you don't so morality is obedience to
legitimate Authority you're better off
if your parents nurtur you than if you
don't morality is nurturance and this
ansers a mystery that the mystery that
led me to write moral politics I
wondered in 1994 when the when the
conservatives took over Congress why
these were very strange people they were
against Taxation and against abortion
what do they have to do with each other
they're against unions and worker rights
what does that have to do with abortion
they're against environmentalism what
does that have to do with taxation
they're against therefore Les a fair
markets what does that have to do with
abortion they're for the use of military
strength uh what does that have to do
with worker rights they're for corporate
personhood for you know for tort reform
against public employee benefits against
public programs what do they have to do
with each other now I looked at this and
I said what is going on here uh and so I
said okay I'm against all of I have the
opposite views and all all of these what
do they have to do with each other for
me I'm a cognitive scientist and I got
embarrassed because I didn't know but
it's a cognitive science problem and I
took it on and it turned out that the
answer to that was contained in those
metaphors for
Morality because you get two models of
the family a strict father family and a
nurtan parent family and the strict
father family is the one that is the
basis of conservatism under a certain
metaphor so let me first tell you about
that
metaphor when are you first
governed in your
family so you learn that a governing
institution is a family it could be a
church it could be a team it could be a
classroom or a
nation okay now there are two models of
the family that are prominent in America
you may or may not be raised under one
or the other you may have both in your
family but they go like this and they're
in our culture uh the strict father
family has Father Knows Best knows right
from wrong he's the ultimate Authority
no one in the family has moral Authority
he must preserve that authority
authority no back talk Authority must be
maintained the father protects and
supports uh the family financially uh
children learn morality by being
punished for Disobedience punishment is
morally required of the father and it
must be painful the child will never
learn what's right and to stop doing
what's wrong morality requires
discipline
so if you're undisciplined you can't be
moral what does that mean if you're
disciplined you can go out in the world
and earn a living if you're not earning
a living then you can't be disciplined
which means you can't be moral which
means you deserve your poverty so the
best people are the people who make the
most
money surprise surprise uh all
responsibility is personal
responsibility follows from this you are
responsible uh every adult is
responsible for satisfying their own
interest there's one way communication a
uh the father in the family is
responsible for reproduction decisions
adults are responsible for their
children what is this explained we're
about to be done there's another one
which is nurturance parents have equal
responsibility empathize with their
children Etc it explains for
example uh why it is that you can be uh
pro-life and for the death
penalty it
explains right
why you pro-life because in the strict
father family the father is the person
who determines
reproduction and therefore if they're
going to be a child he doesn't want to
abort it because he's determined it and
so he'll be against abortion and for
Parental notification and spousal
notification and so on and all of those
rights that is men will be responsible
for women's
reproduction in the strict father family
you apply that to conservatives and it
turns out that the conservative views on
this activate the entire moral
system and it was not stupid for
conservatives to be advocating this it
activates the rest of their system you
apply it to the market it says the
market is the decider let the market
decide that means there should be
nothing above the
market what is above the market
regulation tax a worker rights and torch
cases all the things conservatives are
against now we can go through this bit
by bit the book moral politics spells it
out in 500 pages of easy to read
detail
cheap okay so that's the general idea uh
Bic conceptuals have both there's no
ideology of the middle
Etc
Freedom the freedom to start a business
when you have roads and you have all the
other things you need and re Government
research the freedom to live a decent
life you've got to have roads and sewers
and or and health and and uh and all
those other things for conservatives
democracy is based on a different moral
principle it's the freedom of citizens
to seek their own interests regardless
of the interests of others those who
succeed deserve to those who don't
succeed don't deserve to and this
imposes a moral hierarchy which should
be reflected in political and economic
power what it says is democracy is about
Liberty the Liberty to seek your own
interests without any government
interference without anybody interfering
with you and without anybody helping you
you don't have to help anybody else and
nobody else is supposed to help you okay
that's what you saw in those two
conventions and that's what this is
about smaller government is actually a
government that imposes and supports
that moral system it's not necessarily
smaller because it conservatives by that
mean that it's a government that gets
rid of the public
Provisions right it might increase
defense they might have a bigger deficit
but that doesn't count as a deficit a
deficit for Republicans is only a
deficit caused by public Provisions to
help people not a deficit caused by Wars
or a deficit caused by increased
military spending it's not part of the
concept
deficit they mean different things so
for progressives if the Ryan budget goes
through
it will defund all public Provisions by
2050 91% of all public Provisions will
be gone and as they defund institutions
they destroy them what this means is
destroying the moral basis of democracy
thank
you so thank you once again George so
what we're going to do now is we're
going to have uh uh Heather Professor
Heather Hendershot here moderate
discussion we'll have questions from
audience members as well so we're going
to ask because all of this is being
recorded is for audience members to go
to the mics on either side of the room
in order to ask your questions I know a
lot of people want to have a commentary
Express yourselves have answers and
engagement so try to keep the questions
uh relatively uh brief here and so
without further Ado I'll just turn it
over to Heather great thanks and I think
we also have people who can help pass
the microphones too sometimes it's a
little hard to get up if you're right in
the middle and get to the aisle but just
raise your hand and we'll make sure you
get Amplified somehow um well it was a
very provocative talk I can see people
like I'm dying to say something so let's
open it up we have a good 20 minutes we
might go over a few minutes um who would
like to kick off our first yes okay I'll
ask the obvious question how do you how
would you suggest or give us some
examples of how you would have a
conversation with quote the other side
so it depends on whether they're total
conservatives or whether they're
partially Bic conceptual and most
conservatives are B conceptual in some
ways they have certain Progressive ideas
uh there's a whole chapter of uh uh on
this at the end of a book called uh
don't think of an elephant and there's
what I tell my students when they say
I'm going to go to uh Thanksgiving and
uh my grandfather is going to be there
and we always have a fight right and I
say look don't fight with your
grandfather ask him the following
question what are you most proud of uh
in helping doing something for someone
else for other
people what are you most proud of and
they come back and they say I never knew
my grandfather did three really
important good things in the world maybe
not others but at least three good ones
and they were really very good and we
talk about them every time we get
together and I respect them for at least
doing three good things and that's the
best you can do in a lot of cases but
it's a it's an interesting thing because
conservatism has a lot of ingroup um uh
progressivism ingroup nurturance and out
of group you know apply their their
normal moral theory and you see this in
the Army right the Army is inside the
Army is a socialist Collective uh you
know and it's you know just think about
it for a minute and that's that's how
they work there ingroup nurturance and
this was provoked beautifully by
Michelle Obama and uh Jill Biden in
their talks because what they did was
they talked about helping out veterans
families which evoked nurturance about
the Army and about the military and it
what it did was evoke their moral system
in a discussion of the military which is
vitally important and not one pundit
noticed
okay um thank you uh who's
next here we go uh Chris Peterson
comparative media studies um Professor I
read your critique um what Orwell didn't
know yeah uh and while I agree with your
point that Orwell had suffered from the
editor's fallacy of thinking that words
had discret meanings and everything I
had always thought that the point of his
essay was that metaphors kind of
structured not only what we thought but
what it was capable for us to think so I
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit more about where you saw the gap
between what Orwell understood and what
you understand he certainly understood
that and and I said that I mean he you
know I'm a big Orwell fan and have
always been but Orwell thought that it
was possible simply to tell people the
facts and they would reason to the right
conclusion and he was wrong and this is
important to
understand you can only understand what
the brain circuits you have allow you to
understand and if you don't have enough
available brain circuitry that is that
needs to be recruited every time you
learn something you're you're recruiting
pretty much circuitry that's not used
for anything in particular strengthening
it so it can be used you're doing brain
change if those appropriate circuits are
not
available the facts won't mean anything
to somebody and that happens with
extreme conservatives you can you know
they can hear Clinton's speech it'll go
in one ear and out the other
yes hi Daniel Lois d uh media psychology
and um I know you have a colleague down
south in uh emry Drew Weston uh he's
more I guess of a neuroscientist um
actually he's not he's a clinical
psychologist who has worked once with a
neuroscientist okay thanks for the
clarification I did a very nice job so
you wrote the political mind he wrote
the political brain um I've read both of
them and I was just curious what you see
is the distinctions between what each of
you say and if there's anything not to
start a feud between you two but if
there's anything that uh you guys
disagree on I know there's a lot you
agree on and you actually reference each
other a number of times but um we agree
on many things but there is there are a
couple of major disagreements that are
important uh first um you know he he
isn't a neuroscientist
uh you know although he did was involved
in in this I'm not a neuroscientist
either um he's a clinical
psychologist uh he uh believes in
Enlightenment
reason and he believe and and all of the
things he suggests to the Democrats are
Enlightenment reason arguments you know
get you know get the facts out there and
argue strongly he correctly believes
that emotion is important that you
should do it emotionally and use
emotional rhetoric he correctly believes
that you need to use narratives and
stories he's absolutely right on all of
those calls but he misses B
conceptualism he his suggestions are
often to move to the right to move quote
as he would say to the to the active
Center he's more of a Centrist than a
progressive uh although he he has uh uh
you know written extensively against
Obama's Centrist positions um and
otherwise he's a very very smart very
articulate uh person uh you know and we
have just those those
disagreements thank you i' just going to
interject one here how would you account
for uh differences among Republicans for
example or not Republicans conservatives
um for example that uh the fact that uh
there are Libertarians who identify
themselves
as
person B conceptual or they actually
legitimately very different kinds
or
there is an equal or compelling
body
what they should do same thing and have
the force to back it up but we don't
have enough of a military now we need
more okay so that's part of it there's
another part which is the fact that when
you support the military you support the
military industrial complex which is
you're supporting
corporations which is another part of
the
Romney
father morality I mean when you start
going into the
deep
and who's more moral is by looking at um
in a well-ordered universe ordered by
God who has been ruling in the past you
know God above man man above nature uh
Western culture above non-western
culture adults above children uh men
above women uh Straits above gays
Christians above non-christians etc etc
got it there's a a moral hierarchy there
not all conservatives have all of it
they all have things like America above
other countries and Western culture
above above non-western culture and man
above nature and so on but you know not
all of them are bigots by any means but
but it's part of it's an extension of
the same hierarchy that you get now uh
another very important uh feature when
you study the system in detail is that
uh just as in a strict father family the
authority of the father must be
maintained so the authority of
conservatism must be maintained and
spread that is the highest value in that
system is maintaining and preserving
that system itself and that explains
something a number of things but one of
them is why conservatives would
vote
as you get an ultra conservative
Congress in there they're going to vote
against anything that would help Obama
because that would go against their
moral principles of doing something that
would hurt their own moral
system yes uh George MRA an independent
scholar one of the most interesting
things that I saw within the last year
in public discourse was an interview on
MSNBC oh no it was on current TV with uh
one of the
occupiers and the interesting thing
about one of the interesting things
about the occupiers is of course as soon
as they're introduced they say well I
can't speak for occupy I can only speak
for myself right and this was at the
time when the New York police were
supposedly taking drug addicts and
drunks and other Troublesome people and
saying go to zucati park go there go
there go there and the interviewer was
asking about that and trying
to
I was listening to uh NPR one day when
uh the world had an interview uh with
the uh British ambassador from Sierra
Leon and there was a British interviewer
and she asked the Ambassador about Truth
and Reconciliation he explained uh you
know they had done these awful things
but they were going to get them out in
the open let everybody know about him
and then stop and the interviewer
said
in this presidential campaign it seems
like
Barack
look at Miss compound so it's not really
a pure story Romney's grandfather is a
Mexican immigrant from a polygamous
compound so it doesn't really resonate
purely for him well he didn't mention
that but you know you get you get the
drift of this and then he's heroic
because Bane Capital saved
Staples not mentioning the ones they
destroyed and not mention the kind of
business that they were in I mean you
know but this is the the general way
that this goes in this country those are
major uh narratives that you expect
politicians to have and the Obama
campaign has them uh now that doesn't
mean they will or won't work for the
election or for the election of other
Democrats but they're there and what's
interesting is uh the reaction to that
in the uh in the convention hall because
not everybody in that convention hall
was uh Pro Obama on everything there are
a lot of people there who are much more
Progressive than Obama and they cheered
those narratives too I mean those
narratives are important in our culture
and uh they're using
them whether they'll work I can't
say thanks I think we have time for a
few more questions um yes hi uh I'm
Colin McDonald I'm studying computer in
uh political science right now and uh I
read a book by Richard Thor um and he's
also trying to kind of apply cognitive
science to politics so um for anybody
who hasn't read nudge um I guess he's
trying to suggest that the government
should use theistic and biases that we
know about the human brain uh to try and
make them uh make better decisions and
so I was wondering if you think that's a
good idea bad idea I don't know it
depends on what the decisions are and
some of them have been pretty bad and
some okay uh what you
have yeah you have Cass sunstein was in
the Obama Administration until recently
uh and so was the and Cass sunstein was
uh in the position of pushing cost
benefit analysis now everybody in this
audience will recognize the um equation
for cost benefit analysis it's an
integral and it's an integral um uh over
a particular action um and it starts at
one time and ends at another time and it
has a factor of e to the minus DT where
D is the interest or discount rate which
means and everything must be translated
into money all this everything there so
let's take the environment for an
environmental thing you for you know uh
you take the the benefit minus the cost
time e to the minus DT well uh what that
means means is e minus DT as you know
goes down exponentially with time so
that any environmental benefit uh goes
down exponentially with time and goes to
zero very quickly which means you
shouldn't be using it for the
environment but they do and C sunstein
did I don't like that one two this is
part of uh what um uh is being used uh
to decide what medical tests should be
give to people so for example there's an
argument that on cost benefit analysis
terms that women uh who are 40 should
not get uh uh you know tested for breast
cancer they shouldn't wait until they're
50 because it's only an extra you know
3% of women who would get breast cancer
in that time uh multiply that by 150
million women and you get a number like
45,000 and uh you don't want to talk
about 45,000 deaths even though it's
only
3% uh
somehow some of these uses are not
beneficial some of them can be uh the
ones they always talk about are terrific
you know uh you know do you uh tell
somebody um that they have a choice to
to have a u retirement plan or do you
just tell them they have a retirement
plan and canot opt out you know if they
have to opt out that takes more effort
so more people opt in which is
beneficial they're absolutely right
about that and you know it really
depends upon the particular cases but
the idea of using it across the board as
Thor and sunstein suggest I think is
immoral thank you um we
have we have time for just one more
question can we take yours please uh
yeah so thank you very much I'm an urban
planner and uh I hear a lot uh this kind
of spatial metaphor also in a political
context of top down versus bottom up and
uh people who who use this metapher
usually say that top down is somehow bad
and bottom up is always very positive uh
but I but I but I noticed that uh the
notion of bottom up uh people talk about
very different things both on the on the
left and on the right when they talk
about bottom up so I wanted to ask you
about a comment on on on on this very
frequent uh metaphor um again the issue
is um what it's
about uh so you have uh an idea let's
say um uh in the um case of the 1%
versus the
99% uh the folks who were uh out there
demonstrating uh for the 99% had a
bottomup view in such a case that it
never went up that was a disaster we
needed them to be moving up to be
actually saying something Beyond
individuals saying something uh there
was a very a great lost opportunity and
I'm sad that that happened uh top down
isn't always bad bottom up isn't always
good bottom up isn't always bad top down
isn't always good and so on it depends
on the case uh there are cases where you
really need a leader to do something
when you need a leader to do something
you need it to be topped down there are
cases where ordinary people uh have to
be able to have the ideas first before
it can happen as Obama says make me do
it start a movement make me do it well
in many cases that's right in other
cases it's really a bad idea and you
need leadership it depends on the
particular case and the particular
situation thank you I know we have uh
you all have a lot more questions but um
we are out of time and apparently even
though uh Professor lov's books are very
long they're very read readable and
they're sold at a fair price so that
would be a good way to to continue to
learn more all very long I mean you know
many you you did emphasize the five and
600 Pages oh those are the big ones they
the little blue book is a is very short
don't think of an elephant is very short
metaphors we live by is very short you
know there are a lot of very short very
good so you can read those books to to
follow through and thank you all very
much for
coming
and so we'd also like to thank uh
Heather for her job moderating I just
want to mention briefly the final talk
in this years's cognitive dimensions of
media series by the ice lab and compared
to media studies department will be by
Mark Turner who co-authored a more than
cool reason with uh uh Professor George
LOF here he'll be here in November so
stay out stay on the lookout for that
one as well also we'll engage the news
and finally join me in thanking uh
George Lov one more time before we leave
for leaving
yeah